[Musique]
les choses les plus simples sont parfois
les plus belles prenez un village de 250
habitants une forteresse médiévale et un
maire passionné par sa commune et vous
obtenez yèvre le châtel le seul village
du loir est labellisée plus beau village
de france qui a trente ans de travail
sur cette commune nous avons restauré la
forteresse l'église saint lubin les
remparts et aujourd'hui quand on voit le
succès touristique du village où et on
est très heureux
pour lui parce que
c'est incontestablement un développement
économique pour cette région est riche
et au 10e siècle cette forteresse
protégé à l'époque le royaume de france
qui s'étendait jusqu'au val de loire
aujourd'hui 8000 touristes payent chaque
année l'entrée pour profiter de sa vue
nous avons un point de vue à 360 degrés
de ce côté-ci sur la bosse ce côté ci
c'est le territoire vallonnées du
gâtinais et l'ama sombre qui est là bas
c'est la forêt d'orléans nous sommes aux
confins de trois régions naturelles
[Musique]
tout ce qui est vieille peur vieilles
maisons maisons ont une histoire et
c'est ce qui nous intéresse en fait
découvrir l'histoire du lieu ce qu'il ya
derrière un histoire des gens mais yèvre
le châtel ne se repose pas seulement sur
ses vieilles pierres pour se distinguer
encore le village propose un paysage
coloré exceptionnel une roseraie a été
créé il ya un an et une quatrième fleur
a été décroché dans le cadre du label
villages fleuris des distinctions qui
attire l'oeil des curieux
ne s'est pas arrêtée sans je pense à ça
sur vous avec m c'est ce qui a fait
qu'on s'est arrêtée à 160
en
fait souvent ça pendant les vacances on
cherche les plus beaux villages de
france pour faire l'étape sur la route
en août 1834 c'est un certain victor
hugo qui a été séduit par ce village et
notamment cette église inachevé du xiiie
siècle presque 200 ans plus tard cent
mille visiteurs admirent chaque année
les vestiges et le patrimoine d'yèvre le
châtel